he's the Rams general manager les Snead
joining us les how are you this morning
I'm good how about you Dan I'm
spectacular are you have you moved to LA
I have moved to LA did you buy or rent
you know at this point I'm renting so it
was obviously when the vote went down in
January because oftentimes in this
business there's kids involved you know
was able to get a freshman in high
school into a second semester high
school out here that started February 1
so probably had about two weeks to you
know pack up the house and go west would
you have made this deal if the team was
still in st. Louis definitely I think
you know I think we we made it for the
right reason and and it didn't matter
what system we were gonna be playing in
huh you know you this is a football
decision and we think it's the best
thing you know long-term for the
football team when did you first think
about trading up you know I think the
the it probably was a you know during
the fall as you as you scout you know
certain positions and you and you really
start determining you know who might
help you and who might not and then I
think it really got serious at the
combine per se and when I said that's
what the seed was planted because we
were sitting we were sitting in the 15
hole and and to get you know at least
one of the two guys we needed to to get
to the one hole
especially with Cleveland you know
you're you're suspecting that they're in
the quarterback business as well so at
the combine chatted with John Robinson
just to see hey first of all are they
willing to move out and number two if
they are would they be willing to go
from 1 to 15 which had never been done
before
alright now let the audience in on the
bathroom story oh the oh let ona on the
bathroom story
yes okay I think if the audience doesn't
know the way to combine does a Jeff
foster who runs it you basically have a
draft what suite that you're you're each
club gets a suite so and obviously as we
all know if you're a sweet home
are out there some sweets are better
than others and have better views and
closer to the fifty and what have you
so you basically you know put your name
in a hat and draw all numbers and that's
the sweet you get or that's at least
where your draft slot is and you didn't
get to go pick your sweet but long story
short looked over to my right and our
neighbor was a Tennessee Titan so right
outside of those sweets is a bathroom so
you know I told you know John John and I
could go and you know act like we're
taking care of a little business but you
know have a few meetings in the stalls
per se kind of like Fonzie used to do
maybe so you're discussing trading up
for the number one pick in the bathrooms
well I would tell you this you know that
was probably where it first first
started but really right outside the
restroom you go in and do your business
and then you come out and a lot of
people do that because the way the the
way the the dome is there and Indy you
know each suite doesn't have a restroom
there's a large restroom so you know
there's a lot of clubs going in and out
and and usually after you wash your
hands and all that you come out and in
the hallways you may catch up with old
buddy
so that's it was nothing that was going
to be too obvious so if something
happens all the time but it seems like
it was under you know and I get
clandestine meeting here couldn't you
just talk out in the open or you know
what was the concern there oh there was
no concern I think I just brought up
that story in that that's kind of where
it took place
so and there was a couple of times where
I went over and actually you know
visited with John right outside of his
suite or maybe even in it because in
those Suites each team kind of brings in
food and snacks and and we share snacks
what have you all the time so it was
nothing clandestine I think the point of
the discussion was to really find now
Haworth would they be willing and and if
so with 15 be an option for them I had
the Titans get 1545 4376 first
third-round picks next year in exchange
for a1 113 and 190 how does this compare
to the other deal that I think you're on
the job for a month when you got those
picks in in exchange for the rant or the
Redskins to be able to trade for rg3
oh yeah I think it's very similar and I
feel like at this point we've been able
to wear you know both pairs of shoes you
know and one is moving up and given up
you know picks and the others moving
back and accepting some and I think the
difference for us is this in 2012 if
we're a month on the job you know in tip
you let's call this way those previous
five years for the Rams were really in
terms of 15 wins and five years was one
of the worst stretches of regular season
runs in NFL history think about you know
anywhere from 17 to 19 UFAs that were
owned you're 53 were unrestricted free
agents and didn't signed back in the NFL
so at that point in time we needed a
foundation of core young players made
the trade we felt like it was the best
thing for us and of course you had Sam
Bradford who was coming you know off a
rookie of the year a couple of years but
before that so you had a young QB which
enabled you to get a good young core
foundation we've been the youngest team
in football for four four years running
now so we did feel like because we're
young we could make this trade give up
some picks go get you know one player
that we felt that would you know
stabilize a position in the franchise
for a long term and then we because we
lost those picks we're probably will
have to supplement through free agency
find some veterans with experience that
are the right people for the right job
and put them on the bus he's less need
the Rams GM joining us Dan Patrick show
all right now I'm supposed to believe
that you guys went all-in but you
haven't decided who that number one
overall pick is right I think that's
what you're supposed to believe but I
don't
that is probably rational thing you know
who you're picking well I think I can't
tell you this we have a leader in the
clubhouse obviously but I do think when
you make a move of this magnitude which
was nice for us we did feel like there
was two players we did determine it we
feel like there's two players worthy of
picking there and I think that's
important to know and yes there's a
leader in the clubhouse but we still
have you know you know over over ten
days before the draft Hubley so
not much can happen in that time but a
few things can't happen and you want to
go really really you know I call it
cross your T's dot your i's and put your
period on the sentence but I think you
know you're rational you know but I do
think that there's really no reason for
us to let that be known at this point
has the Commissioner asked you not to
release that information to build up
some height for the draft
oh he has not he is not I have not
gotten a call from Roger so that's uh
that would be if that's out there that's
not true and and so we'll go up but I
think I did make that comment in the
initial initial press conference that I
do think it would be good for the
network's it's true there is real
suspense in that first you know ten or
so minutes does one of these
quarterbacks know have you already told
either Jerrod golfer Carson Wednesday
will be the number one pick we have not
told either of those players I know
there will be the number one pick so I
think you know what you know what what's
awesome is in our head coach has been
through this as a player he has always
said there's you know there's a few
thing there's a few moments in life that
you'll always remember and however many
you have whether it's five or ten but
Jeff always says if you're if you're a
player and you want to play in the NFL
or whatever sport there's nothing like
that phone call you get when the phone
finally rings and there's a team on the
other line and and at the beginning of
your you know your journey begins and a
dream you've been trying to achieve
again will you bring two different
jerseys to the dress that's it that's a
good question I we were and obviously we
relate relocated so there's a lot of
check boxes to check I'm gonna add that
one to the checklist for sure
that's a I didn't have that on the
checklist but you just helped me out
there now you said that you didn't tell
either these quarterbacks no I did I
left out everybody else so there are you
taking a quarterback number one will you
at least acknowledge that I think that
would be you know definitely something
that you can run with okay I don't know
how far I run with that last but you
know I just don't know if that was gonna
make yeah I think you saw something at
the combine and you probably said Jeff
holy smokes we got our guy
and to do your due diligence you're
gonna go through the process there but I
think you fell in love at the combine
maybe got some glimpses during the
regular season and so you're in love I
get that okay so you try to do two you
try to in this business you definitely
try to stay you subtly from falling in
love I you try to keep it you know you
know I would say that a rational peso
you can you can make good sound
decisions but yes and and I do think
this it's it's like you said it's a
process it's more than the combine if
you're going to ever fall in love with a
player you know a lot of times you're
gonna fall in love with that player over
what he's done on the football field
against real competitions with you know
eleven defenders trying to defend him
more than you are at the combine but I
do I can't tell you this too right after
that combine we went and did you know
private workouts with those two young
men real quickly after the combine
because we knew they were in throwing
shape and all of that and we would
probably be better you know suited to
get a glimpse up close and personal more
than hey hanging out in the stands of
the of the dome there and make that
decision you have to fight off falling
in love though right because you can
look at something and say oh my god like
we've all done that like there's an
impulsive you know whatever trait to is
characteristic did you have to fight
that like this may be too good to be
true or we you know we we we can't fall
in love like this Jeff I think you you
when you sit in in this chair or ingest
here you always we always talk about you
you know the objects not to fall in love
and in if you're picking let's say let's
say you're not picking at one let's say
you're picking somewhere else even if
it's fifth in the draft and I don't know
why I picked that number but just
because this is the 2016 rap and you're
picking fifth there's not just one
player on the planet who is perfect for
the five hole there's usually probably
two or three players that are at the
same level of talent maybe maybe not but
oftentimes there is and then the farther
you go back there's more players so you
want to always be able to have options
because you might you might have a team
want to come
come up and and you can get you know
more pics to move back and not falling
in love it's a big part of that but
would are you open to a trade at number
one I think at this point we're not oh
yes we we made the decision this is what
we want to do this is what we felt was
best for the organization right now and
and we're gonna move forward all right
before I let you go and this is why I
wanted to have you on how realistic was
Kevin Costner in role in the movie draft
day you know what what here's what's
interesting the web I'm embarrassed to
say this I have not seen drafted you've
lived so I've lived it and it's so close
to home sometimes I don't like watching
movies that you live now my wife who has
been in the media business watched the
movie and and and she said you know what
there is some elements of reality in
that but like Hollywood does each
element that is actually probably
reality is is you know you know drama on
steroids so very similar but I can tell
you from from listening her that you
know each each each situation is
probably not that dramatic in real life
now have fun over the next few days
they're less we appreciate your time
thanks for joining us
you're welcome thanks for having night
let's listen II Rams Jim the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience